an investigation by CBS News and Reuters
has uncovered misconduct in the private
military housing program while US
service members risk their lives
fighting for our country many of their
families live in dirty and dangerous
homes our investigation found one of the
military's largest housing contractors
apparently misled the Air Force to
qualify for millions of dollars in bonus
payments the FBI is now investigating
Omar Villafranca has been reporting on
this story Omar what have you found
well good morning Balfour Beatty
Communities manages 40,000 homes on 55
military bases across the country and
it's performance bonuses are estimated
to get this be potentially worth about
800 million dollars over decades along
contracts now at installations like
Tinker Air Force Base in Oklahoma City
those bonuses are partially based on
data provided by Balfour Beatty but
documents show some of that data was
falsified driver truck Paige and Nikki
Pulido met while serving in the Navy at
Tinker Air Force Base in 2015 they
quickly moved in together choosing a
house on base managed by Balfour Beatty
Communities the house was a mess to
begin with the floor downstairs was
destroyed completely doors won't close
properly you name it there's probably
something I could have found wrong with
it internal records reviewed by CBS News
and Reuters show that within a year a
leak caused a balfour beatty maintenance
technician to document his concern that
the couple's infant daughter could
become sick from chewing on flooring
tiles that contained asbestos it's very
upsetting to know that he was concerned
for our child safety but didn't tell us
it's almost heartbreaking and then we
already risk our lives every day you
know you think you got your family home
and safe and to find out that you know
get your kid even asbestos floor records
also reveal a startling practice Balfour
Beatty falsified its response time this
says the call was put in at 4:32 p.m.
and they completed the task at 4:52
which is wrong because when we
originally called in it was raining and
they told us they couldn't come out
whenever it was raining it's a physical
impossibility to
something of that extent in 20 minutes
at the time balfour beatty employees at
tinker kept two sets of books calls were
first recorded on paper and entered into
a computer system monitored by the air
force only when a job was nearly
completed this made it appear that the
company was responding quickly to
residents problems and kept it eligible
for millions in performance-based
bonuses
whenever you generate a work order it
automatically puts today's date on it
and it's like a stopwatch so if you
entered into the computer they were
automatically on the clock exactly in
2014 Tina Brown was hired by Balfour
Beatty to schedule repairs at tinker did
they give you any Express directions to
not enter things into a computer yes
definitely the management was all
concerned about appearances and
collecting their bonuses and appearing
right for corporate in a statement Val
for BT said it has not and does not
condone the falsification of records in
any way according to the company
allegations of misconduct at tinker date
back several years and after being
investigated by the Air Force one
employee was found to have acted
improperly do you feel like you were the
scapegoat yes definitely I know I was
brown an hourly employee who received no
performance bonus was fired in 2016 no
one else was reprimanded and she's now
suing for wrongful termination balfour
beatty stinker base manager at the time
told Reuters the request to dr.
maintenance records came from his
superiors and company training documents
instructed employees to modify and
correct work orders to comply with
mandated response times did you ever
feel like you were doing something wrong
I did yes how did you square that away I
just did what I was told since 2015
military housing officials at tinker and
two other bases issued more than a dozen
warnings about Balfour Beatty
maintenance logs but the Air Force only
suspended incentive payments last year
Assistant Secretary of the Air Force
John Henderson told CBS News his office
takes the health and safety of airmen
and their families seriously
when inaccurate data was discovered the
Air Force placed balfour beatty on a
corrective action plan and referred
allegations of fraud to the FBI right
here this is all water the company says
it has since work to strengthen its
documentation process at tinker but
several families say maintenance and
record-keeping problems continue
doorframes starting to fall apart Derek
a naval flight engineer who asked us not
to use his last name lives on base but
has deployed more than half the year
leaving his wife Jennifer and three kids
to deal with frequent housing issues the
fact that they're actually making a
profit and being able to get their
bonuses it's just ludicrous people need
to be held accountable for these
conditions they need to be held
accountable
Derek pays $1400 a month for a house
that it has it's had mold ant problems
repeated water leaks but Balfour BT's
maintenance records say that many of
those problems have been fixed there are
ongoing investigations into similar
record-keeping practices at Travis Air
Force Base that's in California
Fairchild Air Force Base in Washington
both are also managed oh my god at the
top that Balfour has 800 million dollars
in potential bonuses in the contract if
they're getting bonuses for falsifying
records and that's shown to be true is
any that money gonna come back that is a
big question is is there going to be a
clawback of some of that money and how
that happens that's why the feds are
involved now there's a bout for betty
has a 50-year Contour 50 year contract
so 800 million is a big number over over
50 years but that's still 800 million
dollars is real money sure you wonder is
that contract in jeopardy now have to
wait and see we'll see
good to see you indoors Thank You Omar